it's been quite a few months of activity
in Yellowstone National Park steamboat
geyser the world's tallest is
approaching a record number of eruptions
this year and last month ear spring
dormant since 1957 erupted with some
surprising results I got there just
after the eruption and it was pretty
amazing what I saw after the hot spring
belched water up to 30 feet in the air
Park officials found this piles of
manmade debris there was an incredible
wash the water had just washed out under
the boardwalk and had strewn trash all
around including a cement block cans
dozens of coins and a baby's pacifier
that dates back to the 1930s the trash
as being catalogue now and could become
part of Yellowstone's archives as a
reminder to the millions of visitors to
not use the parks natural wonders as a
dumping ground you might think that if
you toss something in a hot spring or in
a geyser that it kind of disappears but
it doesn't disappear it stays in that
and what normally happens is you can
actually plug up a feature and kill the
future and that's happened in many
places in the park killing many places
filled in many places in the park
that's one big giant belch that was way
to look at Crete pacify here's going in
there lesson learned